what's the deal with airplane peanuts
peanuts every summer the Just for Laughs
Comedy Festival in Montreal hosts a
Comedy Award Show where they honor the
year's top comedians in categories like
breakout comic of the Year comedy person
of the year and most importantly the
comedian of the Year this year's winner
was none other than the machine himself
Bert Kreischer which is a decision that
seems to have caught a large amount of
Comedy fans by surprise I'm in Montreal
and Providence
for JFL me too oh nice nice I just just
agreed you that's awesome okay and then
uh Philly yeah
what are you doing cleaning hotels
I'm one comedian of the year I'm just
accepting whoa
I'm actually just carrying the award out
I have been waiting to say that
sometimes I drew you into it are you
doing a show like of course
the comedian of the year is based
largely around what each comic has
accomplished in the last calendar year
since the previous award show it feels
like most people who were confused why
Bert won this award were suggesting
other comedians in the comments who they
personally find funnier than Bert and
things should have won obviously when
you see an award titled comedian of the
year it sounds like the equivalent of
maybe like an MVP trophy in sports which
is supposed to go to the very best
player from That season in sports those
tough guys are usually fairly agreed
upon and it's pretty obvious who
performed the best based on the stats
and the team records but it's way harder
to do that with comedy stand-up is so
subjective what one person finds super
funny other people might find completely
annoying and cringe some people think
Brian Holtzman is what real comedy
should be other people are fans of
Hannah Gatsby apparently although I'm
not technically sure who if you're JFL
trying to give out an award for comedian
of the year the only possible way to
rank and rate every comic in the world
against each other spanning all these
different styles and philosophies is to
just look at the numbers meaning what
did each person accomplish career-wise
in the past 12 months and once you start
thinking about it in that context nobody
in comedy even comes close to competing
with Bart crystals since 2023 started
eight months ago Bert Kreischer has been
on a tear unlike anything we've ever
seen before including a full-length
Netflix special Razzle Dazzle in March a
multi-million dollar Blockbuster movie
about his life in May the fully loaded
Festival in June and July where he
invites dozens of the world's best
comedians to perform in baseball
stadiums all around the country not to
mention the tops off World Tour where he
traveled the globe with three semi
trucks full of equipment to perform in
every City's largest possible venue
selling 20 000 tickets a night in NBA
arenas the industry of it the Commerce
of it is so far more than it was when I
started there was a list of what Comics
made last year want to guess what he
made on the road
well I I have no idea that's a million
dollars I'm sorry how many 25 million
dollars Bert did yes
my God good for him yeah when we first
posted the news about Bert Kreischer
winning this award in our community
section there were hundreds of comments
from joke World subscribers who were
saying that they think Shane Gillis
should have won this award which
definitely makes sense if your thought
process is along the lines of Shane
Gillis is the funniest comedian right
now so therefore he should be comedian
of the year however this award seems to
be based largely on building a resume of
tangible accomplishments that a
committee can point to and say this guy
had the best year because of this list
of things not just well Shane's really
funny on stage and in podcasts Annie has
a lot of fans so he should win by that
logic Dave Chappelle could automatically
win this award every single year just
based on the most people considering him
the goat I personally feel like the
community surrounding this channel has
the best sense of humor in terms of
which comedians we all support which is
why this upcoming December we're gonna
open voting for The Joke World comedian
of the Year decided solely by subscriber
vote count that way this award will be
the most die-hard comedy fans in the
world deciding who the 2023 people's
champ is congratulations to bird on one
hell of a year always pushing the limits
of this industry finding New Paths and
using his vast reach to promote great
Comedians and the craziest part is it
doesn't look like that machine is
slowing down anytime soon there's a
brand new comedic short film out on
YouTube right now titled gut punch that
features multiple comedians like joeless
and radel Ortiz the movie is only 12
minutes long which is the perfect length
for a quick watch and is extremely well
produced throughout Joe list stars in
the short film as one of the main
characters the acting is great the
storyline is funny and overall it's just
really well done if you want to support
more independent projects you can find
gut punch right now on John Ryan
sujimoto's YouTube channel guest spots
from last week The Joe Rogan Experience
had on Jim Gaffigan ymh talked with Tony
Hinchcliffe Mark Norman was on are you
garbage Steven Soderberg was a guest on
Whiskey ginger kill Tony this week was
with Don Barris two bears one cave was
Bert and Rob Lowe flagrant had on judion
the blocks podcast talked with Tom
segora Jeremiah Watkins was a guest on
the Heartland Highway we might be drunk
with just the boys and Sebastian was the
guest on tigerbelly so like you never
probably smoked weed before it was
what's his name
is his name is Al Capone or Al Capone do
you take notes I'll show you yeah he
does guess what he works that's why
we're he he takes notes of things that I
could get in trouble for so everything's
fine Al Capone okay so it really is and
I don't know if you're gonna use this or
you were recording when we were talking
about podcasts yeah but this is an elite
podcast that is making generating
Revenue right we have sponsors there's
stuff going on yeah my podcast that I
have yeah doesn't have this type of
Revenue stream okay and it's nice to see
how a podcast that's making
a nice nice chunk of change operates and
based on what I'm seeing here this is
easy
I wouldn't tell you though I gotta say
something though this past weekend with
the Yvonne talked with Hulk Hogan
Heather Hardy was the guest on Chrissy
chaos taste buds battle childhood versus
adulthood with Rick Glassman Gareth
Reynolds was on the Honeydew Rob Eiler
was on first date Jared freed was the
guest on hey babe Whitney Cummings went
on take your shoes off being in with
Jordan had on Joe DeRosa and Joanne
Angel and we interviewed Mark Norman
last week right here on the joke World
comedy news as far as new stand-up
specials are either out right now or
coming out soon Jim Gaffigan is put out
special number 10 which is insane his
new hour is titled dark pale and is
available right now on Prime video Mark
Norman Soup To Nuts is currently
trending on Netflix if you haven't seen
that yet be sure to check it out and if
you enjoyed Mark's new special
definitely consider checking out the
mark norm and try not to laugh
compilation that we posted to this
channel on Sunday there's also a few
specials that are in the works right now
coming out soon that we can look forward
to including Nick Mullen who's recording
a special in Denver the weekend of
August 18th that will be released on his
personal YouTube channel so be sure to
go subscribe there the best of all of
them the king that guy B go you remember
him the guy who took a [__] on Nancy
Pelosi's death
regardless of your politics that man
should be a hero to you for that alone
and every
we have a busted July video that's going
to be uploaded to this channel on
Thursday including some of the funniest
moments from all your favorite podcasts
last month you've never dealt with a
chafed thigh before Mark oh I was a fat
kid right and you remember I
skateboarded in the Louisiana heat so
this was a swampy Katrina Wuhan wet
Market down here it was bad did you have
any uh did you have any like remedies
for it how did you just fix it I found
well I got a I was uh I hooked up with a
soccer player in college what was his
name
[Laughter]
be sure to subscribe to joke world now
and turn on the post notifications if
you don't want to miss that video other
than that there's even more comedy
content on our second Channel clip world
you can go subscribe there you can
follow us on Instagram if you just want
some more joke World comedy news Style
videos and you know content in your life
other than that thank you for watching
this video and have a great week
at Joe
and the world is wrld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out